hey guys I'm Jess it is August the 25th
and you're watching gamespot news
bungie's destiny currently lacks
matchmaking support for raids that it
sounds like that could be changing well
design leed Steve cotton told UK
publication Metro that the studio have
been considering whether to introduce
the feature back in 2014 lead designer
Luke Smith said a looking for group
feature is something Bungie absolutely
wants to do today cotton went on to say
that wild Bungie does make a point of
listening to fan feedback the team often
focuses on providing more new content as
opposed to the creation of additional
features that said the highly requested
private match support feature for
crucible mode is coming with the rise of
iron expansion in September Activision
has officially revealed the final DLC
pack for call duty black ops 3 as well
as a trailer for its zombies mode the
pack called salvation is comprised of
four multiplayer maps as well as
revelations the new zombies mission that
concludes the zombies storyline the
official press release reads Richtofen
at dempsey to care and nikolai finally
come face-to-face with the mysterious
dr. Monte in the house confronted by an
ancient evil our heroes must fight the
zombie horde once more in the final
battle to save their immortal souls the
DLCs multiplayer maps includes Citadel
where you're fighting close quarters in
an ancient castle micro that takes place
on a militarized war zone at a family's
picnic table the western-style outlaw
which is a reimagining of the standoff
map from black ops 2 and finally rupture
a pre-emergent futuristic version of the
call of duty world at war outskirts map
you can pick up salvation on its own for
15 bucks or as a part of the
fifty-dollar season pass it launches for
ps4 on sep tember sixth and will be
available on Xbox one and PC about a
month later finally Ubisoft has revealed
that the divisions upcoming expansions
have been delayed the game's second DLC
survival will now be out at a later date
this year while the last stand expansion
is now jus in early 2017 he be explained
this new schedule will not only enable
us to strengthen the core XP
before adding new content but also
continuously improve it by allowing for
more production time to ensure the
quality of future updates as well
survival was originally slated to arrive
this summer while the last stand was to
be out this winter Ubisoft also added
that the overall division experience has
been affected by lingering issues that
have accumulated since release they said
their priority is shifting on to
improving the core gameplay experience
as opposed to increasing new content so
the opposite of what Bungie are doing if
you'll remember back to stories ago
Ubisoft are currently working on a new
update that will fix bugs rebalance
zones and equipment and improve loot
drops among other things head to
gamespot the stories on quantum break
and mortal kombat x and come back again
tomorrow for the top 5 stories at the
entire week and see them